it's been three years since the
instagram post rebecca vardy is suing
over but determined to clear her name
she finally took to the stand colleen
rooney's lawyers laying straight into
vardy citing an interview she gave about
sleeping with peter andre suggesting she
has little respect for privacy the court
also shown a message between vardy and
her agent on another subject where vardy
questions can we not leak her story
showing her disappointment after being
told no vardy's lawyers argue rooney
revelled in being called wagatha
christie over her now infamous post
revealing an elaborate sting to work out
who was leaking stories on her to the
sun newspaper now i know for certain she
said which account individual it's come
from i have saved and screenshotted all
the original stories which clearly show
just one person has viewed them it's
rebecca vardy's account it was an
instant shaming according to vardy
trolling death threats and public
humiliation setting out their case
vardy's lawyers argue that their defense
is the truth that there is no
irrefutable evidence that proves what
clean rooney is alleging and that the
post was obviously defamatory
but like a whodunit rooney's lawyers
argued you won't necessarily find the
culprit with a smoking gun in their hand
comparing vardy to someone directing a
hitman her agent caroline watt they
claim may have been the fall guy
as for deleted evidence vardy's team
argued there are credible boring
explanations of how her agent's phone
was lost in the north sea how whatsapp
files became unavailable
rebecca vardy's evidence is due to
continue until thursday after that
colleen rooney will get her say waging
the so-called wag wars all in the name
of reputation with eye-watering legal
costs they can apparently afford to
swallow katie spencer sky news